[Music]
the wives have no idea where they're
going
or who they'll be living with it's
nerve-wracking because tombstone
is a unique individual it takes a
special woman to tolerate him
and her husband is called tombstone the
white girl's husband is called
tombstone what can you gather from that
name
why do you think he's called tombstone
maybe he works in a graveyard
where he's a biker before they meet
their new families
carrie and kiera have a chance to look
around their new homes
i see the motorcycle okay tombstone
sounds like a motorcycle game
like some of my people the one
percenters in the bike world one
percenters are
like you're you're you're outlaws okay
no it's not bike
it's your outlet it's not everybody that
has a bike or a patch in the back that
are
outlaws you know you have the two
patches your three patches
i'm considered a two patch two patches
you have the emblem of your
of your bike gang and you have the name
that's two pass that's inoffensive that
is they don't do nothing and there's
three patches
where there's a logo there's the name of
your gang and then there's the city
that's a three patch that's a one
percenter that's
that's keep it a buck i wasn't listening
to another it's all good you went from
one pass to two patched
three patches the two packed of two
batches to breakdowns like [ __ ]
first off revise your [ __ ] and the
click you claimed
oh god you cut that where's fireworks
you claim to be a player but this
suitcase might be too big to take in
it i see some rusty weights which means
they probably don't work out
damn
[Music]
oh workout stuff no idea what this is or
what it's used for
oh stinks in here definitely love
motorcycles
i'm nervous that he will be the
stereotypical
biker thug it's kind of nice for a
change here in a black girl referral
white dude
yeah like all your typical you know yeah
i don't want to say the word
you know adolf thug you know it's like
the first time i discovered cheese
i didn't know i needed that in my life
until i had it and then i'm like [ __ ]
give me that feta on everything
it feels nice you you don't like well
you know you don't
you don't know velveeta i know velveeta
now but when i didn't know velveeta i
didn't want a novelty day
it's just interesting because i'm
hearing that i'm like i never hear that
we should start referring to white
people's nick come that
well i'm not calling a white person nick
[Music]
cannon
[Laughter]
dirty dishes in the sink i want to do
them so bad
doing the dishes that is a woman's place
what's wrong
what's wrong i don't agree with you you
don't feel like it's a woman's place to
do the dishes no
whose place is it whoever made them
dirty
clean your goddamn [ __ ] whoever made
them dirty
that's it are these cigarettes in the
freezer
they got tons of ramen noodles
no i see
some spinach cheese 100
vegan cheese vegan oh no they don't eat
meat
okay can we just stop pretending like
vegan meat is the bane of everyone's
existence like
if you've ever had someone make you
really good vegan food it tastes fine
it's actually really good nutrition
yeah it's fine vegan food is not the
problem the problem is vegans
yeah yeah aaron aaron your comment
that's not vegan
maybe you don't want to eat it every day
i understand but let's stop pretending
like eating a vegan meal is like the
scariest thing
i would it's delicious i would eat it
every day no problem
i feel the same way but a lot of people
i could understand for their diets
for their dietary needs it may not be
the most optimal thing for whatever
lifestyle they want but the thing is
that vegan food
used to be disgusting it used to be but
that's when you know
people were not exploring you know they
were like uh ew vegan food and no no
but it was really just they were not
embracing the spices
yeah so it was pretty dry and leafy
but there's great vegan food out there
so i don't know i feel like that's
stigma hopefully with more time
yeah maybe you don't have great access
to vegan restaurants in your area so
maybe that kind of colors
because we also have to admit that vegan
food generally was always seen as a very
bougie thing
but if you happen to live in an area
where there's low low income
opportunities for you to get access try
it out there's some really good spots
you know i think that's one thing that
we're really fortunate about living here
in this city
yeah there's so much access to
affordable delicious food
from different cultures and different
different um
dietary regimens if you will absolutely
kerry
and kiara have each written a manual to
guide the new wife with the running of
their home
my husband kp and i are high school
sweethearts
oh my biker husband tombstone
is the love of my life and i am his
ride-or-die biker [ __ ]
so i ride on tombstones what does that
mean
you know what that's how y'all talk to
each other there's nothing wrong with it
no if that's your thing that's your
thing that's what it is
my girl is definitely not my ride or
diet micro [ __ ] i am a singer
dancer fitness guru and influencer
real talk i'd rather be known as a biker
[ __ ] than an influencer
i'm not even front with you bro
something about the term influencer and
people of color makes me cringe yeah
every time someone tells me like oh yo
you're an influencer no no no
it's people that are influenced luckily
kp
is not only my husband but my manager
but i'm the boss
i believe in old fashioned family
values women need to be seen and not
hurt
this is what i'm saying if that's your
relationship that's fine but saying
stuff like women need to be seen or not
heard
a woman's place is doing the dishes like
maybe for your relationship that's your
place
if you in your relationship you have to
understand that's fine but saying like
a woman's place is here or in a man's
place just like
i i cringe so hard when i hear stuff
like that men don't know how to be
men anymore oh boy
don't get me or tombstone started at
stay-at-home
dads uh excuse me my husband is
a stay-at-home dad and he's definitely a
man
okay there's no pussification in my
house
you know what if that works for them
great i know a lot of people won't clown
that or clown a man like listen any
father choose to be
present in the child's life i'm gonna
respect and any father who's fine with
the wife as long as the wife respects
him and shows him that difference and
doesn't
belittle him as a result of that that's
great and it should be like that vice
versa
even if i make the most amount of income
in my relationship i will not treat my
partner lesser than because they're
spending more time at home
so if that's your relationship i mean
what's wrong with that and i think
calling people [ __ ] because they
don't subscribe to your
ideal relationship i know it just seems
very juvenile
am i wrong i i believe the same kp and i
basically
share chores in the household so
king of the house cleans his home i
think the king of the house should be
able to enjoy his home
not clean it you know what you can do
both i enjoy my home more when i clean
it
and i enjoy the idea of picking up my
weight you know like okay cool
the person i'm with they cook more often
than i do but i also like making them a
meal every now and then just like
taking the burden off of them just to
break the monotony of everyday life
this idea that you can enjoy your home
because you've cleaned it is ridiculous
to me personally that's really
definitely not my thing it's archaic but
whatever floats your boat
you clean this you can't enjoy it i mean
i wash my car does not mean that i can't
enjoy my car
i wash my bike it means i can't enjoy my
bike because i cleaned it
you understand what i'm saying so it
doesn't really make sense to me
but whatever it's now time for the wives
to meet their new husbands
and families
[Music]
hey hi she's like hey
oh she's black first coming into my
castle
my throne and of course you got to live
our way first right
so you so you believe in women not being
hurt being seen and not heard
i mean that's more or less the rules of
the house
hi say hi what's your name
hey papa squat right here baby
so you're big on the whole helping with
the children
oh yeah every day i am the main child
care oh okay and house cleaner
and person in the kitchen because that
is a woman's place
no what's your favorite food
we eat bacon yeah i saw that
and you're not vegan i've only been
vegan since february and what was your
deciding factor
my wife asked me to his wife asked
him to
[Music]
she has a problem with wife giving
decisions
it wasn't decision it was a request i
understand what you're saying
he she asked yeah she didn't demand she
asked i get that
but that's not how she the woman to her
is not even supposed to talk yeah so her
just had asking for things is her
transgression dressing
the rules that the woman can or cannot
do yeah people were like whoa why would
he change because yes but
maybe because he was open to it he
tasted so much good vegan food that he
was fine
you know people i've seen who are in
relationships one of them is vegan the
other one's not and after the eating of
vegan food like oh i can do this
she makes such good vegan food i'm fine
with it it happens to pro
athletes it happens to people on a
regular level like there's nothing wrong
with it
you know we might rag on vegans because
like the stereotypical vegans sometimes
are so cringy
as far as the vegan diet the food you
don't do
any chores no you don't cook or clean or
no and you don't uh you don't eat
healthy at all
no i'm vegan did you know that
when kiara says that she's a vegan it
scares me
would you be willing to try healthy food
people over the years they've tried to
change me if nobody's been able to
change me yet
good luck you know what this makes me
think of when you think of that country
song
i love my religion love my guns and i
love this country
and that should be all of our attitudes
because this
is america and a country boy is good
enough for me
and there's like bagpipes playing in the
background it's just like you don't like
backpacks
well i do it's just so like yeah i think
they sound great
i wouldn't put a kilt on and do do this
but i respect it you know
on this topic specifically here's how i
feel i think people are free to want
whatever relationship that they want
but i think it gets a little bit strange
when people like this is a woman's role
or this is where a woman belongs that's
why i'm like
ugh but that's just me what about you me
i mean i always see my parents do you
know
things equally so that's not a problem
for me you know i mean it'll work like
that yeah that's what i want to
like work with because i got some things
i'm worried i'm good at there's some
things i'm not that good at so
it's just like a team effort you know i
mean i don't want to dictate everything
and everything and stuff there's some
things that might be wrong or not be
able to do
so yeah it is everybody got their
strengths and
that's what it is i said it the best i
said it i i keep on saying that
i'm gonna say it again uh woman should
go in the kitchen man should go in the
kitchen there's food in there let's cook
let's go so you don't think that a
woman's place is in the kitchen
yeah it is that's the sort of soil it's
a man as well it's in the kitchen
we cook let's go there's food in there
if you're in the kitchen making food and
i'm in the kitchen we're going to eat
twice faster you understand what i'm
saying
so i'm let's go let's go but that's how
i think if people don't think like that
that's that's on them that's on them
whatever
yeah some people give in different ways
if you don't want to reciprocate in the
kitchen and cleaning maybe you give in
financial ways
or in time spent or whatever that's fine
and if that's how you
guys get your balance that's okay yeah
that's okay because it's good for you
and it works for you
i just don't think it's necessarily like
the prototype for necessarily all
relationships and i think we all agree
on that but i thought
that that and then that's me that's just
the way i see things it's like
being with the kids i see my i see my
dad spending time with me
and it was like i remember like i got
memories of my dad
taking us from school and he was not
working that day and he brought us to
the skating rink and my sister she was
doing uh figure skating at the time
and he just bought me skates because she
was kidding i'm gonna escape
so we were skating before school and
then we went back home like i got
memories of that
would i have to be my mom to take care
of that all the time no she was working
he could and it's memories that i have
with my dad it's memories that i have
with my dad
and it's great memories so i don't know
why you wouldn't want that but if that's
your thing
that is your thing it's not i made kids
to my wife
no we had kids together and i take care
of it but that's just that's me that's
how i was raised
that's how cc thinks i want to be
involved with my kids and i want to have
memories with them yeah yeah as long as
both parties are consenting and they
both feel that way then i don't care
it's messed up that some people have the
only memory that they have with their
dad
is the dad beating them or the dad is
only the disciplinary thing
well i mean just because you live in
that traditional size doesn't mean you
don't spend time with your kid
you don't take time with your kids after
work that's fine
that's not what i said i said there are
some people that the only memories that
they have of their dad
is the dad disciplining them i'm not
saying that because you live in a more
traditional way
you don't spend time with a kid that's
not what i'm saying but there's some
people that have that that that's that
thing
the memories that they have is the kids
just hey what you what the hell you
doing here you put down the noise
god damn it and then leave and the dad
doesn't take care of the kids other than
that
but i i i want to help with this like
all the things that have to be done
around the house as well as taking care
of the kids
what do you guys think we wanted to hear
from you guys so leave your comments
below